if you became a hero based on what you
feared what would you be I'd be
mathematics this is versus the GameSpot
show that pits your favorite games
consoles franchises and hot-button
issues against each other this week
Batman nearly the whole UK office has
been replaying the Batman returned to
Arkham collection and now fights are
erupting over which is the best in the
Batman Arkham series fighting for the
dark sheep of the family
Batman Arkham Knight is two more Huseyin
who is a self-confessed Batman Nutter
who actually owns a bat towel that he
wears as a cape and argue in the case
for the series critical darling Batman
Arkham City is Lucy James who has been
ill with a cough over the past week and
can now do a perfect Christian Bale
Batman impersonation
each are going to argue the corner for
their game over the course of this
episode with the overall winner being
decided by you though wonderful viewers
last week's fight between hitman and
Dishonored saw Lucy win with 67% of the
vote for her argument for Dishonored but
to vote for who you think argue their
case better on this episode we're going
to be throwing up a clickable poll right
here on YouTube right let's get into the
bat debate
[Music]
so when we suggested that we were going
to do Batman this week and I said have
you got any Batman props I figured we'd
be talking more about like figures you
don't need you already own this yes are
you gonna speak like this for the entire
episodes yes is that no painful little
bit weird episode this week the cares a
couple months ago you were like oh look
we're turn to Arkham's on sale and
pretty much everyone in the office
bought it because wanted to revisit
those games and so we've all been
replaying the Batman Arkham games and
today we were like oh let's let's decide
you know what type of vs. episode about
which one is the best one
before we start Lucy yeah I'm gonna tell
you something I'm Batman oh my god it's
me I've been Batman the entire time it's
really hot in that mask so we all love
these games I'm arguing in favor of
Arkham Knight it reviewed really well
but it still has the sentiment around it
where people hate it for some reason the
reason is that PC thing where it got
caught up in the PC drama where it
wasn't a great port and the kind of
whenever someone talks about Arkham
Knight now they're kind of that that
kind of negativity is baked into it
Arkham Knight is an incredible game as
much as I love Arkham Asylum and city
and even origins I think as a whole
Arkham Knight is the best at making you
feel like Batman it takes everything
that is done so far in the investigation
and figuring puzzles out and exploring
environments from asylum the open-world
element where you can actually roleplay
as Batman and you know hide around
corners and on rooftops and pounce on
your enemy and then it adds in finally
the Batmobile which is an essential part
of being Batman like the Batmobile is so
cool I love calling the Batmobile I love
driving around in a Batmobile I love
working a Batmobile into the combat and
puzzle solving the only part I don't
like is the racecar stuff like the the
Riddler stuff and all of it makes you
feel like a Batman as a whole when you
add it up to like all the villains and
that kind of stuff
on top of that like it is a stunning
game it's it's a bigger world than
Arkham City and obviously Asylum its in
Gotham instead of a closed-off area and
you get so much like space to become the
Batman and like fly around and now that
you can traverse in the air and also on
the ground it's just so much freedom of
movement and that's what it kind of like
is about the feeling of being Batman
like you feel like a proper predator in
that city there's one video that I've
got on my youtube which like perfectly
encapsulates what I love about their
game and the Batmobile there's this
moment where I'm like flipping a switch
and all these thugs come up and try to
ambush me and I do they're kind of like
the combat and at the very last moment
like I've got one enemy left I hit the
button to call the Batmobile and then do
a few punches knock the guy into the air
and then the Batmobile comes skidding
around the corner and the very last hit
that knocks him out is the back of the
Batmobile kind of skidding in front of
me and then I just jump in the Batmobile
that is like the best Batman moment you
can ask for like that's why I love that
game and I saw so it's got the best
story we'll come to that later story
when we when we were talking about like
replaying the Batman Arkham games I was
for sure in my head like oh well asylum
obviously is the best one it's an
incredible game but it has aged but then
when you go from asylum which is already
an incredible game city could have been
a mess yeah
City is just such an incredible game
from the get-go from everything
everything about it the way that they've
taken an already incredible combat
system and it can be as easy or as
complex as you want but the way that
they easily just introduce new gadgets
and you moves you know you finishing
moves everything into that and then the
way that like they open out Arkham City
I think it's a smart move not going
straight from asylum to the massive huge
open world Gotham for having this like
enclosed area because even like compared
to night it's smaller but it feels like
there is so much more to do and they
start seeding things like zazz and the
phone like and the phones and like just
these random events that pop up as
you're flying around to briefly mention
of our night isn't my wine night is not
my favorite is I love us so much they're
like introducing a weapons will for
example focusing more on fear because
that is an integral part of Batman is
that he aims to strike fear in the
hearts of criminals and I love that they
embrace that in terms of game
like fear takedowns anything but night
for me just felt a bit overwhelming with
the amount of things that were there
yeah I feel like the the thing that you
like the weapon will for example like I
feel like the one thing that I kind of
detracted from the experience in Knight
that kind of stems from city is it has a
similar I think it has roughly similar
amount of like side stuff to do but it
very much like gamma Phi's it I
understand why they game if I denied so
much moist because the beautiful thing
about Arkham City was how you would
never expect the things that are
happening to you for example like the
Azrael stuff where you don't really know
anything about Azrael for the entirety
of the game and you don't really is
nothing signposting saying like you need
to look over here and just have a fight
you turn and then you see someone
standing on a rooftop in a distance and
he's just glaring at you and like you go
over to him and over the course of that
entire game he reveals that he's trying
to be your successor he's Azrael in this
game it's a little more like hey look at
this
it's a it's I can you understand like
they put so much effort and time into
making it they're worried that no one's
gonna see this so they make that wheel
thing but like it pulls you out
experience but it also kind of like you
get to see the stuff then so it's tricky
but like it is there's so much to it I
can understand why you wouldn't like it
but at the same time like it's so much
fun to do so I think one of the most
underrated parts of Arkham Knight is
something that we touched on before is
the story it's it's not remembered as
being like as interesting as the other
games and in my mind it actually is way
more complex I think a lot of the
nuances of that story and what it
achieves is overshadowed by the Arkham
Knight character the part of it I kind
of was able to compartmentalize and
focus on the rest of the story and I
think it's got the most interesting
story as I said before like it because
it tries to deconstruct Batman as a
character but also it's it's an original
story that what I found really
interesting was it also kind of touched
kind of like it connected two really
important moments from existing Batman
Law so like you know the moment when
Joker shoots Barbara Gordon in Killing
Joke and that kind of stuff there's
various touchstones like that Batman
fans will enjoy and I love the way a
kind of weaved an original story around
the kind of touchstones
law which was really interesting and
then the way he brought back job well
back Joker was really really I thought
was really cool I know a lot of people
were like ask another Joker thing overly
reliant on Joker and to some extent sure
but like what it's about - story without
Joker and how do you bring that
character back a third time without
being really lame like he fell into a
Lazarus Pit and he's back now and it's
so cool like he is Batman they are one
of the same they're he's he's in your
mind and he's in there every moment and
also kind of the Arkham Knight thing
where they you know reveal his history
and how it happened there was that it is
that it's kind of corny and it's kind of
annoying that you're kind of like I hate
this character already but when it got
to the other leaning on the death and
the family thing or different from the
comics where that character was treated
you know really badly and you know led
to Red Hood and that kind of stuff yeah
they used that and I was like I like
that I'm not super fond of the character
and the way his story kind of has panned
out but I like that they used that
element of the story from the law to be
the kind of foundation for his character
within this so I overall think it's got
the best story of three games so I think
Asylum has the best story but then
that's because it's obviously their
comic who which is you know beloved and
well-regarded but I think City story is
actually really quite good because it
has this framework which could be
annoying but the way that they space out
actually I think they did a time out of
it really well and the way out like you
said about Joker the way that he's
included and the way that he's not
overbearing Lee involved but then you
have like the guys on the ground like in
asylum
it would just be oh this guy's escaped
yeah this guy is escaped she's escaped
you go beat him up and take him out or
is it this one you feel like you get to
know the characters a little bit better
the pacing is really good on it I think
of one thing that I now go in hindsight
look at him I'm like not as good as I
remember it to be is the way it
concludes I'm not a fan of because you
have that like small arc wave Talia and
Rach and you take him out and then like
the next thing you do is
if you're finishing up the game Hugo
Strange starts talking revealing that
there's someone else where he's working
with his master and it's rich and you're
like I've already kicked your ass that
part of it kind of unfolds for me
I think Arkham Knights story goes for
more and like all of the three stories
like the the other the other two feel
like good versus evil how can we work in
all these villains at the same time I
think for ce4 night they were like it
feels more like they've got our
chessboard and they're trying to figure
out a story and it's their own unique
story in a way yeah for me as a fan it
feels like fans writing a story for
Batman fans more than like fans and
people who work who have worked in
Batman
hitting all the notes that a Batman
story should hit these games man
yeah I played I completed city before I
started Asylum and like I still think
that's a ten out of ten game but like I
think we can both and everyone can agree
like that series is exceptional Rock
City what you doing mate what's the next
game let us know who you think won the
debate by voting in our poll in the top
right corner video or if you're ever on
games.com by putting your thoughts in
the comments section below
he'll be your votes that decide who wins
so make yourselves heard right time for
this week's quickfire round a series of
dumb fun questions written by the rest
of the UK team let's see how Tom and
Lucy get on in real life who's your
Robin what reality show would Batman be
more successful on the Great British
Bake Off or love Island he is a master
of the martial arts yeah the world's
greatest detective he can do anything he
sets his mind to he would absolutely
100% just become a master pause for
space cause Baker just because you can
if you want to bake you a cake you can
do that if you need some dank drugs you
can do that if you need like an antidote
so fear toxin is got it covered
if you became a hero based on what you
feared what would you be Christ's IV
Pennywise the clown
I'd be mathematics I think it's not even
kidding you I'm terrible at math and it
terrifies me in my maths exam it's
started by the teacher going like okay
begin
about three minute pause and then I just
threw up do your best
swear to me alright remember to get your
voice heard in our poll or in the
comments section below and tell us who
you think are cute that case better and
if you enjoy this episode versus make
sure to hit that subscribe button as
we'll have new episodes the show every
Wednesday thanks for watching see ya
[Music]
you